i want to talk about real world use
cases and obviously um
you have so many uh customers kind of on
each side of the marketplace maybe talk
through you know one or two examples of
the types of infrastructure providers
and the types of companies that are
actually using this
sure sure sure so i'll uh i'll talk
about um
customers people who are actually
storing data with us right um
and it's a pretty broad group of people
um
uh we've got uh you know we've got
people who are storing
video and uh and photos and things like
that and
we give them a fast easy way to share
data we're seeing a lot of usage
among academic uh data sets right now
right where
you've got a massive data set of let's
say climate data
or energy data you know or health data
and you want to be able to share that
securely with large numbers of people
make it really fast to get it out there
we're just an excellent solution for
doing that because it's
very secure very durable and yet the
data can get extremely fast
everybody wants to use it um we're also
seeing some more
uh you know more relevance probably the
area that you spent
spend time and we've got a few people
who are actually using us as a way to
get
blockchain data distributed so
blockchains themselves are pretty
massive right and
in an ideal world it's really easy for
anybody who's running a node
to be able to get the entire blockchain
and get it quickly
ethereum classic wrote about how they're
using us but lots of others were using
as well
to get get data out there and get it
distributed quickly and securely
interestingly part of what you get when
you decentralize
storage you get this massive improvement
in privacy and security
so as i mentioned you know every file
that gets uploaded to us
gets encrypted before it gets uploaded
then gets split up into
80 pieces each of which goes to a
different drive on the network that only
knows that they have a piece and so
if a hacker wanted to get at that file
they'd have to find
any drives out of you know you know
thousands or hundreds of thousands
compromise each one all they would get
would be an encrypted file and even if
they manage to somehow depict that
the next file they go after is going to
be different so if you're storing like
you know really sensitive personal data
we're a great solution
uh you remember a few years ago equifax
got reached
you know so millions of people's
personal data got compromised
because one you know incompetent
administrator equifax
configured a print server incorrectly um
with us that just can't happen right not
only
can we scroll up but you can't scroll
so that's those are the kinds of use
cases that we're seeing is
highly secure highly fast highly private
data that needs to get
stored and distributed globally is sort
of our sweet spot
and are there situations where companies
are choosing kind of centralized and
decentralized uh
solutions side by side so i may be a
company
i've got some storage you know needs uh
and i may actually
split this between both centralized and
decentralized um yeah maybe talk a
little bit about that
yeah i mean so so um you know most of
our our customers
you know right now have some data that
they're storing locally in their own
data center and then some data that
they're storing let's say in amazon or
google or
you know or microsoft um and generally
speaking what they will do with us is
they'll say okay i'm going to give you
10
of my new and i'm going to try you out
and so
uh you know every day as i'm running
jobs and creating data i'm gonna push my
my backups to you or my snapshots to you
and see how you do
and then over time what they're what
they're saying is gosh
this is great rather giving you 10 of
the new data i create
let me give you 50 70 of the data that i
create
and then at some point they may take the
data that they're currently storing into
amazon
plus that's that'll be great but um
you know what i think is uh
as sort of an important truism is that
if you're going to be doing something
disruptive
it can be disruptive but you don't want
to be you don't want your customers to
experience it
in a revolutionary way you want to give
them the opportunity to experience in an
evolutionary way
because
explain that that is very very good
advice but explain that
sure i i mean we as a brand new company
can take on lots and lots of risks right
if our but our customers um
you know most customers don't want to
have to change what they're doing
in order to get advantage right to ask a
customer to completely change everything
that they do how they write their code
how they
how they store it what their risk
profile is is asking a lot
right and so what we'd like to do is be
able to give people
you know the ability to say hey i'm
going to change three lines of code
suddenly i'm using storage and it's
cheaper faster better
more secure i love it and i'm gonna
evolve to do more and more over time
with
with us and you know the more they do
with us the more
uh benefit they can get but asking them
to change their world
for us is a non-starter
that uh that makes sense what's the
biggest challenges uh as you guys kind
of move forward
what do you spend your time thinking the
most about that you guys need to either
solve for
uh or kind of come up with solutions uh
sure i mean we you know we spent a ton
of time making sure that we offered a
decentralized storage solution that was
you know high availability high
performance had a large enough number of
nodes
ran really well we actually had a
year-long beta process
uh you know what we didn't use a single
file which was important
for us but you know making sure that
what we were offering was rock solid we
the last thing we wanted to do was be
the first
to market with a decentralized storage
system have people get excited about it
and then and then fail because we
wouldn't just be failing
for ourselves we'd be failing for the
whole industry um
uh so we spend a lot of time doing that
we spend a lot of time on incentives
uh we want to make it really right
incentives in place for people who are
running the notes they're profitable
and easy and they're not they're not
surprised by what they have and they
also that we don't set the wrong
incentives right
we don't want to incent bad behavior
and then a lot of it is you know the
normal
blocking and channeling and building a
great company building great culture
building a great community um and you
know that's that's a challenge but it's
also really fun
but ultimately the community is so much
larger than the company and the company
is